how are you as fears grow from years ago
here in Tokyo I mean how is this this is
not bad at all yeah Japan does it right
holy crap it's amazing look really it
genuinely amazing do you remember your
first ever experience with Pokemon
before this movie was ever I think you
know I'm not one of those guys that's
gonna sit here and dole out I was such a
fan I didn't know that much about it I
knew of it just because it's massive
yeah
you could be any porcupine I mean other
than Pikachu Pikachu
what would you be anything buggy
squirtle my daughter's pretty obsessed
with squirtle what's gonna be her
reaction when she sees you and figures
out that it's you yeah ice picture I
think she'd be pretty excited I don't is
the first time she's ever been like
truly pumped to see a movie I'm in so I
think it's like a little bit next level
and a little scary like it's kind of
weird that she's sort of recognizing
that no so I don't know how I'm gonna
play that we'll see you think that uh
Pikachu of Deadpool would get along they
make a pretty good duo that's it that's
it that's it crossing the universe kinda
thing that'd be pretty good but no can
make it happen who's here yeah and it
sounded very similar thanks a lot
you